[Music]
hey everyone welcome back to our podcast
and the series called High School
memories my name is Alon and I'll be
your host so without further Ado let's
get started today's topic is school
bullying and what it is uh bullying
definition bullying in schools is a
systematic problem that affects all
schools districts in the United States
in uh
2016 the national Center for educational
sta statistics reported that one in five
students has been bullied in school
bullying is a repeated aggressive
behavior characterized by power
imbalance and the intent to C to cause
harm students who are bullied often feel
threatened and Powerless while bullying
can be destructive and persistent it can
also be subtle enough the teachers are
not aware of it since bullying can lead
to long lasting psychological emotional
and physical problems it is essential
for Teacher to recognize the signs of
bullying and how to combat
it uh types of bullying the three types
of bullying students can experience are
direct bullying indirect and cyber
bullying Within These categories like
verbal physical and social or R
relational
bullying direct bullying is a
combination of both verbal and physical
bullying verbal bullying involves spoken
comments or written information that is
emotionally damaging to a targeted
student
physical bullying consist of physically
harming a student other position
possession an example of direct bullying
is hitting a student while also calling
them rude names or forcing F language
indirect bullying is mainly verbal and
is experienced frequently in
schools as an example of such Behavior
Behavior would be a student spreading
false information about another student
with the attempt to cause
humiliation the rise of techn technology
has been taken bullying to the to the
internet cyber bullying is when students
use email or social media platforms like
Facebook to write damaging content a
2015 Centers for Disease Control study
found that
15.5% of high school students are Cyber
Bullied while 24% of middle schoolers
are Cyber Bullied a common form of Cy
buing is sharing a student's private
photos or videos without their consent
this form of BU bullying is more uh
indous and often takes place of high
school grounds so it's more difficult
for teachers to detect and
address similar to cyber bullying social
or relational bullying is when students
gossip or spread rumors toward the
reputation of the students being bullied
causes of bullying the causes of for
bullying are varied many any students
can become a Target regards of gender
race religion uh or
status understanding Why students bully
others can help teachers better combat
it factors that can lead to bullying
include differences in appearence social
status race and sexual orientation the
national Center for educational
statistic found that 25% of
African-American students were bullied
in
2016 while 22% % of Caucasian students
177% of Hispanic students and 9% of
Asian students were some students who
bully other have low
self-esteem however there are others
that have much higher
self-confidence these with high
self-confidence uh tend to lack
compression and empathy who can respond
aggressively when whenever they feel
threatened current soci shal events and
conversation can compound bullying
problems as an example bullying based on
sexual orientations has increased as the
conversations surrounding
lgbtq have increased in in recent
years in some cases students need
attention and the desire to be perceived
as Brave and
confident uh cause them to
bully students who experience issues at
home such as abuse a neglect or a
divorce can cause them to bully others
due to despair anger or jealousy effects
of bullying bullying uh during inative
school years can have long lasting
effects students who are bullied may
have poor academic performance as their
interest and participation in school
decreases and The Unexplained injuries
and self-destructive Behavior can
occur a 2016 National Center for
educational statistics service reveals
that 14% of bullish students struggle
Academy emotional effects include
struggles with low self-esteem insomnia
depression and suicidal thoughts and
actions in in addition students who are
bullied are twice as likely to to suffer
from health problems such as stomach
issues or headaches
Etc bullying does not impact the student
students but also their family and
classmates feeling powerless and
Confused parents and other family
members of bullying targets may
experience depression anxiety and S
stress related
illnesses some parents become
overprotective of the children if they
feel they fail to protect them friends
and classmates of students who is
bullied may feel powerless to help guilt
over not standing up for the Target and
feel fearful of becoming the next
Target so uh the best way to avoid
bulling is uh first of all to learn how
to
fight personally personally I do
kickboxing and ever since I have not
been bullied well not to say I've been
bullied but I've not been made jokes by
my
friends so my best advice is to learn
how to fight anything boxing kickboxing
mu Tha karate taond
Etc second is uh how
to another advice do not draw attention
to yourself like do not show that you
are being touched from the jokes because
this makes it more satisfying for the
bully to bring you
down uh sometimes is better to not fight
back because uh bullies can be sometimes
strong because uh from their anger
issues at home anger they become more
powerful do not talk to them because
talking to them will give a chance to be
mean or be disrespect disrespectful to
you do not react to bully rude remarks
so that you can make sure that you
didn't express any distress this is
because when the bully sees that you can
that you are not being touched he just
doesn't find anything more
fun kill them with
kindnesses uh if they're mean to
you say something kind to them don't
always be
rude because uh things can go south very
fast don't be scared to the bullies
always stand your ground and don't
uh
and do not show any distress or
emotional touch because then the bullies
will find your weak point and uh make
jokes about it to bring you even more
down so that makes
it the things that you can do to avoid
bullying thank you so much for joining
us on the episode of high school
memories until next time take
care
[Music]